and this dude listen he starts to
his whole demeanor changes
and he starts to stutter a little bit
he's like hey i'm uh i uh
i'm mom i'm uh
i'm i'm wait i'm on weight on the front
yard
and i go did you just develop a stutter
and he goes yeah he said i
i
i just uh i stutter when i get nervous
i'm like oh okay
and he goes i'm gonna wait in the front
yard i go oh okay so he goes on the
front yard now guys this is the type of
child i am as soon as that door shut i
grabbed a chair
i placed it directly in front of the
front door five feet in front of it just
like this so when my wife came home i
could show her who won that battle
[Music]
and so
i'm sitting there she opens the door and
i go hey she goes hey she goes what are
you doing
i go do you see the tutor and she goes
is the tutor here i go he's in the front
yard she goes why is he in the front
yard
and then her phone rings and she goes
hello
he did what
i go is that the tutor is that the tutor
is that the tutor
she goes yeah
did you sexually harass him
and i went is he real
and she goes what the [ __ ] does that
mean is he real
jacob comes in right she goes is the
tutor here and my wife goes ask your dad
and i go i
think i made a mistake
and he goes what are you talking about i
thought that he wasn't real and he goes
what does that mean i go i don't even
know
i said what was this guy an actual tutor
and and my wife was like yes i go why
didn't why was i here to talk to him
and she was like i wanted to go pick up
jacob and jacob goes dad
did you chase him away
and i go no
i go we'll just get another tutor he was
like no dad i have social anxiety he has
social anxiety it's the reason we got
him it was the perfect match for me and
now i can't even have him as a tutor and
i'm like
i [ __ ] up
don't know what to tell you and i turn
to my wife i go hey i go tell him i go
tell him
to come back over here tomorrow i go i
need to apologize to him tell him to
come back and she goes okay hold on
hey he doesn't want to talk to you
and i was like well i got to apologize
to him
guys here's the deal man here's a couple
things you need to know about me i am a
bit of an [ __ ]
but i'm not a bully
i don't punch down
i'm not making fun of people with
disabilities that's not my deal man and
i feel like i need to apologize to your
face the way i was raised is that that's
the way if you can apologize to
someone's face not on the phone not on
text not on email because on the face
face to face that's the hardest place to
do it right and i told her i go you
gotta you gotta bring him back so i can
apologize she was like she he doesn't
wanna see you i go well i'll surprise
him she was like you think that's a good
idea
are you gonna jump out of the bush i'm
like no
that would be funny but i i know
[Music]
i go let me just i'm gonna open the door
i'm gonna apologize i'm gonna walk past
she goes okay i'll have him come
so the next day
there's a knock on the door
and i open it up
and there he is and i'm like
hey buddy
and before i could say anything i don't
know if you guys are familiar with what
a panic attack looks like
my man he started he went to his chest
he's bent over he's stuttering
he drops to a knee
i'm like oh my god and i'm not prepared
i'm rubbing this guy's back i'm like oh
and i called jacob i go jacob call the
doctor i'm not prepared i don't know how
to handle this and i don't want
something bad to happen to this kid you
know i'm like i'm so sorry man i'm
really so sorry and i can hear jacob on
the phone like yeah
no i don't know no my dad saw it you
know my dad's not okay hold on and he
hands me the phone
and i go hello and i just hear jacob go
got you
[Applause]
what about this guy right here and he
looks up from the ground and he goes
good good good good gotcha
i go
wait a second yesterday and jacob was
like yesterday was the joke we hadn't i
could not believe you sniffed him out
yesterday but i knew you wouldn't
believe he came back twice to prank you
and i was like that's [ __ ] up i go
what about the stutter and the guy was
like i thought of that yesterday i'm
like [ __ ] good good good one dude
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]